Freunde ich bin wieder in Düsseldorf um
genau zu sein auf der Immermannstraße
denn die Immermannstraße ist das Herz
der japan-town in Düsseldorf und aus
Japan soll das beste Gericht der Welt
kommen welches wir natürlich im heutigen
Video Essen werden machen wir uns auf
die Suche und finden wir heraus warum es
so gut sein soll
[Musik]
und das ist genau was wir gesucht haben
Karree heißt das ganze ich hoffe ich
spreche richtig aus wie immer andere
Sprache Nagel dich nicht drauf fest aber
das heißt so viel wie Curry japanisches
Curry und das ist laut der Community von
Taste Atlas Nummer eins in der gesamten
Welt ich bin sehr gespannt wie gut es
wirklich ist weil es sieht relativ
unscheinbar aus ist gleich auf dem
Teller aussieht gucken wir noch mal aber
das beste Gericht in der Welt das muss
ja krass sein also wirklich gucken wir
mal reinstellen wir das ganze müssen
noch ein bisschen der Schlange warten
aber es wird sich lohnen da bin ich mir
sicher
[Musik]
eine Viertelstunde in der Schlange
später haben wir jetzt einen Platz
bekommen und ich sage euch so viel das
Restaurant ist schon richtig entspannt
wir sind direkt neben Takumi wo wir
schon mal waren und es ist so richtig
warm gemütlich und ich habe das Gefühl
es wird richtig richtig gut ich habe
gefühlt auch 24 Stunden nichts gegessen
also wahrscheinlich könnte man jetzt
auch ein Blattsalat geben und ich würde
sagen ist das beste aller Zeiten aber
ich war wirklich überrascht muss ich
sagen als ich erfahren habe dass Karl
das beste Gericht der Welt sein soll ich
kann das halt nicht mal und ich meine
viele von euch kennen wahrscheinlich
auch nicht klar Curry kennt man aber das
japanisches Curry so unglaublich gut
sein soll hat mich doch ein bisschen
überrascht ich habe ein paar
Nachforschung angestellt und das
unterscheidet sich so ein bisschen von
den anderen Paris die man kennt ihr
häufig so ins Rohkost Schafe gehen das
geht so ein bisschen in süßliche so ein
bisschen dickere Konsistenz aber wir
werden es ja gleich sehen deshalb gucken
wir mal in die Karte hinein auch wenn
eigentlich schon klar steht was für
bestellen werden der ganze Laden wird
auf jeden Fall ganz normale authentisch
kleines schaudert wenn ihr mehr am Japan
Thema interessiert seid schaut mal bei
Randy und Lukas vorbei die haben da eine
lange Zeit verbracht und natürlich auch
noch viele viele weitere insights
gegeben aber hier ist die Seite unseres
Begehrens hier ist die Curry rise Seite
ich bin ehrlich gespannt wie es ist
sieht er aus wie so eine Bratensoße
Braten sowieso gravy das ist irgendwie
außergewöhnlich aber wir bestellen
chicken Katze und zwar Maishähnchenbrust
Katze Reis Suppe und Salat 18,50 €
wohlgemerkt also der Laden hier
spezialisiert sich halt auf Katzen auf
dieses knusprige panierte Hähnchen
schneiden wir auch immer mit pancopanade
deshalb lecker wird es glaube ich auf
jeden Fall aber wir legen natürlich den
Fokus auf die Soße heute wir suchen uns
mal was lustiges zu trinken dazu aus
weil hier gibt's auch viele verschiedene
Dinge falls ich aber fraglich überhaupt
drauf kommen dass das die Nummer eins
sein soll wie gesagt bei Taste Atlas ist
eine große Plattform die Bewertung
zulässt für verschiedene Gerichte auf
der gesamten Welt die kommt glaube ich
aus Bulgarien hat aber eine weltweite
Community dort wurde abgestimmt und laut
dem ist auch Platz 1 Jahre ich sage
jetzt ab sofort nur noch Curry ich fühle
mich dumm wenn ich sage Curry aus Japan
Platz 1 direkt darunter pikania aus
Brasilien natürlich auch unglaublich gut
aber die 100 beste werteten Gerichte in
der Welt 2022 ne eindeutige Nummer eins
mit 4,92 ich meine dafür muss ja
wirklich etwas unglaublich gut schmecken
das aus vielen bewertenden 4,92 als
Gesamtbewertung rauskommen von fünf
möglichen wohlgemerkt Sonne das kann
kaum jemandem nicht schmecken und ich
glaube das ist auch der Grund weshalb so
populäre Sachen die Döner Pizza Burger
nicht auf der Liste sind weil die
vielleicht einfach bei Leuten nicht so
diese Gefühle auslösen deshalb bin ich
gespannt unter den Top Ten Gerichten
haben wir pikan ja wir haben Bau aus
China wir haben Panik Curry Thailand
Shisha Kebab also wirklich große Sachen
die in vielen Ländern sehr beliebt sind
ich glaube wir müssen uns aber einfach
selbst überzeugen und ich freue mich
sehr wir haben echt lange gewartet danke
schön
[Musik]
wirklich ich habe so unfassbar Lust
drauf das jetzt zu probieren deshalb
rede ich gar nicht lange nehme hier mal
so ein Stückchen von dem frittierten
chicken Katze der saftig innen drin Tipp
ist in die Currysauce und wir probieren
irgendwie vertraut irgendwie vertrauter
Geschmack und was erinnerst mich weißt
woran mich das erinnert so in ganz
kleinen leichten an so Currysoße von der
Currywurst ja genau ganz klassischer
Currysauce
Mischung und japanisches Curry
entscheidet sich dementsprechend
natürlich von indischen Curry oder wie
auch immer aber hat so ein vertrauten
Geschmack das ist relativ dickflüssig
aber nicht unfassbar dickflüssig ein
bisschen von dem Reis mit Curry
es ist ein bisschen Besonderes ist
wirklich ein bisschen außergewöhnlich
weil beschrieb unfassbar gut ne und man
kann nicht schlechtes dagegen sagen aber
es ist nicht unbedingt krass halt alles
andere weißt du ich weiß nicht ich mag
auf jeden Fall auch diesen Reis dazu und
so ne dieses dieser sticky right
ist auch klar dass das beste Gericht der
Welten einfaches ist irgendwie aber du
musst das auch mal probieren ich finde
das ist so ganz anders weil das so ohne
Kokosnussmilch ist irgendwie weißt du ja
ich würde sagen dieses Curry basiert
glaube ich auch sonst du und
dementsprechend hat es eine andere Basis
als Curry dass man kennt grün war genau
eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt das ist
auch ultra lecker irgendwie schwer zu
beschreiben an und für sich weil es
irgendwie vertraut aber irgendwie was
anderes ist als was man kennt so ein
bisschen wie eine Bratensoße mit Curry
angereichert hat
im Hintergrund ich weiß es nicht man hat
halt auch noch nie gegessen
mit der Curry passte oder Currysoße viel
mehr
gerade wenn es so richtig so lustig ist
dann ist das schon geil weil du hast so
vollmundigen Geschmack von dieser Brühe
Soße wie auch immer und die Textur vom
Reis ist schon sehr sehr geil aber ich
glaube es ist für mich nicht die Nummer
eins in der Welt es gibt so viele geile
Sachen aber dass mir noch was dazu
eingefallen ich stelle euch das mal hier
an der Seite ein als Testat lass dir
Ergebnisse gepostet hat haben die
geschrieben wir haben nur die Nummer
angezählt hatet uns nicht weil ich
glaube es ist unmöglich objektiv zu
sagen welches Essen das beste der Welt
ist das hat halt bei einer Plattform die
sich mal getraut hat sowas wie ein
Rating zu machen den ersten Platz belegt
weil sonst traut sich ja niemand zu
sagen hey das ist das beste Essen der
Welt so auch eine geile Erkenntnis so
dass es für dich so safe sogar nicht das
geilste der Welt ist und das muss es ja
auch nicht genau das beste Gericht der
Welt sondern es ist einfach Objektiv das
beste bewertete Gericht auf der Welt auf
dieser Plattform ich kann auch nicht zu
100% nachvollziehen warum weil wie
gesagt übelst lecker keine Frage wenn
ich das Bewerten müsste ich würde
wahrscheinlich so eine so einen neuen
von Ideen geben aber den für mich besten
Gericht der Welt würde ich halt mit 12
von 10 gehen
so gerade ein bisschen so als ob es
nicht schmecken würde aber so ist es ja
ganz gar nicht das schmeckt übelst krank
aber wir sind halt hier mit der
Erwartungshaltung hingegangen so also
erwarten jetzt das aller aller beste der
Welt so was bedeutet das vielleicht war
das auch ein kleiner Fehler ich glaube
das war kein Fehler weil das war das was
wir herausfinden wollen ist das am
besten bewertete Gericht der Welt
wirklich das für uns beste der Welt
Antwort nein sollte man ausprobieren
unbedingt das Katzen mit allen möglichen
aber irgendwie hätte ich mir denken
können dass das Auto für mich ist dass
ich das beste aller Zeiten esse sondern
das hat Geschmäcker verschieden sind
trotzdem finde ich das cool dem auf den
Grund zu gehen und herauszufinden so was
ist das beste der Welt so aber würde ich
sagen essen wir das alles noch mal auf
lass uns ein bisschen auf uns wirklich
machen ein paar Gedanken aber es ist
schon bisschen ähnlich dann wenn man vom
Besten der Welt ausgeht
danke schön so die Leute stehen schon
wieder in der Schlange ich muss sagen es
war ein schöner Restaurantbesuch wir
haben was leckeres Neues probiert so
keine Frage aber wie gesagt sind halt
einige Leute die dafür gebaut haben eine
Sache möchte ich euch noch kurz zeigen
bevor ihr sagt ey was hat er sich dafür
eine Website rausgesucht der Taste
anders ist schon so eine kleine
Institution in dem Bereich bei der hat
komplett so Community getrieben ist das
sind nicht irgendwelche Leute die sagen
dass das Beste sondern die Leute die
Nutzer entscheiden was das Beste ist und
es wurden auch die besten Küchen also
die besten Landesküchen der Welt
verglichen und ich glaube da würde
wahrscheinlich der ein oder andere von
euch zustimmen Platz 1 Italien danach
Griechenland Spanien dann kommt Japan
ich glaube japanische Küche hat halt
auch einfach viel zu bieten aber selbst
aus japanischen Küche war das heute
wahrscheinlich nicht mein
Lieblingsgericht interessantes Video
heute ich habe eigentlich damit
gerechnet oder gehofft dass mich das
übelst umhauen wird hat es aber nicht
dann sind vielleicht auch mal die auf
die Kosten gekommen die sagen dass wir
immer alles übelst gut schmeckt wer weiß
vielleicht sind wir bald mal wieder
zurück weil ein Tag essen gehen tschüss
schaffen wir 100.000 likes
[Musik]